[Music]
like many developers interested in
microservices you start off dabbling
with google kubernetes engine of a
powerful cluster manager and
orchestration system for running your
docker containers first you accept all
the defaults and then slowly start
modifying a few parameters to support
your application as you spend more time
your confidence increases more traffic
and mission-critical applications move
to GK which is great you will be able to
benefit from GK ease advanced cluster
management features soon enough your
cluster size gradually starts increasing
things seems to be going fine until one
day when you start hitting scalability
and manageability issues that can often
be avoided by implementing some key best
practices during cluster creation over
the next few sections we'll be covering
some of the best practices features and
designs in GK networking that can help
you scale and manage your GK footprint
as your business grows first let's talk
about VPC native clusters as you know
kubernetes mandates direct pod to pod
connectivity but there is more than one
way to achieve this by default
kubernetes uses static routes for pod
networking which requires the kubernetes
control plane to maintain these routes
to each node this comes at a scaling
cost in gke
we give you the option to create
clusters and VPC native mode which
provides container native networking BBC
native node is enabled with a single
click and enables connectivity between
all the pods in your V PC without the
overhead of route scaling the V PC
control panel automatically manages
routing setup for pods and the native
integration of container networking in
the V PC fabric improves scalability and
integration between kubernetes and other
V PC features kubernetes also makes very
liberal use of IP addresses which
simplifies the system and makes it
easier to use and comprehend but on the
flip side
this makes IP management a challenge for
kubernetes deployment this is
exacerbated in a hybrid deployment or
where IPs are fragmented making IPs a
scarce resource VPC native sources by
providing flat
civility in defining your cluster scale
requirements upfront for resources like
pods nodes and services so instead of
having hundred resources and thousands
of IPs you can now have hundred
resources 128 eyepiece this allows for
kubernetes to reduce his IP footprint
thereby improving the overall IP
utilization VPC native clusters also
enable other enterprise-grade features
for example sharing VP sees between
projects I am and role separation
providing anti-spoofing security in our
Sdn stack and also private clusters for
cluster isolation
apart from scaling security is another
criteria that needs to be considered in
best practice enterprise users require a
deployment in which your services and
networks are isolated and accessible
only within trusted boundaries gke
provides through private clusters
private clusters makes the worker node
and the cluster max master accessible
only within the trusted boundaries any
unauthorized access to a control plane
is set to default deny for a road body
you use case in enterprise private
cluster also provides a wall garden
access to control plane through private
endpoints which is provisioned by the
customer another best practice to be
aware of for applications at scale is
how you expose your services to the
Internet when you need to deploy your
applications you may start off using a
cluster based ingress controller such as
engine X or H a proxy this is really
familiar for a lot of us it's just a
standard proxy that you would run on
your laptop you would then expose your
application to the Internet using a
layer 4 kubernetes service load balancer
however when your application scales up
you will want to use the Google ingress
implementation in gke the gke container
native ingress is a globally scalable
low latency distributed proxy layer that
supports many of the built-in features
such as caching authentication and DDoS
protection you won't want to fiddle with
how many instances of your proxies to
scale up - or worry about how to absorb
an attack in addition the Google ingress
has built-in support for container
native load balancing using Network
endpoint groups this means that the
network traffic will be balanced
directly to the container in your V PC
keeping the overhead of bouncing through
the kubernetes queue proxy layer you
will also be able to easily debug your
traffic as your connections no longer
need address translation to get to their
destination there are also other subtle
advantages you advantages of using
Google ingress instead of cluster based
controllers such as connection imbalance
and accurate end-to-end health checks
for your backends gke makes the job of
deploying a scalable kubernetes much
less daunting and offers many features
that allow you to future-proof your
deployment we have only scratched the
surface here and there are many other
techniques that helps in scalability and
manageability of your cluster please
attend the hy beat three one four
session at next twenty nineteen SF to
learn more about these tools and tips
[Music]
you